[music playing]
I sure lucked
out with how many
dandelions there are here, even
though I don't care for them.
There's something
happening when I stand up,
and I'm getting
these head rushes.
They worry me a little bit.
I know I had head rushes
bad on Vancouver Island,
but not that bad.
I'm hoping they'll go away.
Well, I harvested quite
a bit of dandelion.
So let's go fishing.
Head rush, head rush--
how come I get a head rush?
I need some fish, man,
lots and lots of fish.
[bleep]
That was a big one too.
God, that's disappointing.
Come on man, I need more fish.
Let's go.
Please, Mongolia, please
let me get this fish, eh?
I got one.
Thank you.
Oh, [bleep], yeah!
Yeah!
[bleep], yeah!
Whoa!
Yeah!
Whoo!
Oh, thank you, Mongolia.
Thank you, Mongolia.
Oh, a head rush, head rush.
Time to cook up some vittles.
What I needed, morale
booster, nourishment--
I mean, I just can't
say enough about it.
Whoa.
Oh.
Well, that was a pretty
intense head rush.
I've never had a head
rush like this before.
This is the worst
one I've ever had.
I blacked out.
I hit my head, just
very, very glancing.
But it could have
been pretty bad.
I'm laying on my back.
And I'm staring at
the sky thinking, that
is a really blue, pretty sky.
And then slowly, my
brain fog starts to lift.
And I realize I'm in
Mongolia, and I'm on my back,
and I just fell.
I think those dandelions have
been dehydrating me pretty bad.
The problem is I think those
dandelions are a diuretic,
which makes you pee.
And if they make you
pee, then they're
keeping my urine color clear.
So I'm thinking that I'm
hydrated when I'm really not.
I'm hoping that cutting
the dandelions out
of my diet, at
least temporarily,
will correct these head rushes.
It's disconcerting to tip
over from a head rush.
So that's something that
I really need to watch.
Something small can
turn into something big
out here in the wilderness
if you let it go.
We are out in the
middle of nowhere.
If you do something
catastrophic,
you're just screwed.